i happened to be in a store which had a
television
i actually saw something happening on
the screen as i went in oh gosh my son's
in new york i hope he's nowhere near
that
literally because i didn't know
and so then i came home and then the
world ended for me
joy's son
was just 29 when he was killed
oli bennett had arrived at a morning
conference at the world trade center on
the 11th of september 2001.
but he never left
it's extraordinary uh
it's such such a long time in years
it's it's
almost unbelievable but it doesn't feel
like that for me
it literally feels like yesterday
we we've missed so much of what he might
have been
um
of
any
of any connection with him anymore ever
that's that's death isn't it
if people say how many children have you
got
i'm not going to say i had one child i
have two children
but then you have to say the next bit
and it's so shocking
that you shock the other person so it's
very difficult
and that's like every day of my life
ollie was one of 67 british people who
died that day
there were others who managed to get out
janice brooks moved from london to new
york just three weeks before the planes
hit
she was starting her dream job all we
did was go to work complete innocent in
it not this
and to lose
61 people that's all
and that's why i do this
and listen
this isn't about me it's about trying to
honor the honor of the day
remember the day
on this 20th anniversary of 9 11 the
families of the british victims will
gather in private
but events of the last month in
afghanistan
have brought anger for many it's been a
lot of change a lot of political shift
but especially with what's happened in
the last four weeks are we in a a safer
world
from events that happened that day yeah
i don't i i personally don't think we
are at all
and um you know by
by
by what we've done in this last three or
four weeks i mean you know other people
might not think that's very clever and
i think the world is not in a safe place
damn whitehead sky news